graphing trigonometric functions is a
pretty important skill right it's
especially going to be it's going to be
kinda like doubly important in the next
part of motion that we're looking at
which is called simple harmonic motion
where you basically take objects that
move and their motion can be modeled
with a trigonometric function like this
or like sine okay so you're gonna get
questions like hey graph this and I want
to just walk you quickly through what's
the what's the main skill that this is
actually assessing and what would you
actually do the approaches right so I'm
going to show you not one not two but
three ways to do this really quickly
ways to model in your brain and you
check each of them off yourself so
you're like okay I have confirmation
that I've done this correctly so if they
showed you this and they said graph this
in you know normal domain which is um
not 2 pi is what you're expecting okay
by the way even though you might be
expecting that 95% of the case that will
be what you get they can change this
what might be a common way to change it
what kinds of other ways have you seen
in the exams you've been doing you might
go from negative PI for instance to PI
so you're going to get the same amount
of the curve but you're going to start
over here you're gonna start some
negative portion and then go not quite
as far or they might go go further go to
4 pi give me two copies of the whole
graph so do do you pay attention to this
it's not always the same but in this
case what would we do okay the first
thing you need to remember is please
please please by this point you need to
have graphed enough trig functions that
you have a basic idea of what a cosine
curve looks like I hope that image is
like involuntarily leaping into your
mind if it's not do yourself a favor and
draw a really rough one on the side so
you've got something to mentally compare
to just to reduce that we call it
cognitive load to me things in your
brain that's where silly mistakes
happened right like I'm trying to
remember too many things in my head and
manipulate it all and then you get
confused okay so if you've got this
picture here here's what regular cos
looks like and there are two
modifications to it that you can see in
the graph that I've given you right
what does this 3 do what is that do this
changes the amplitude so normal normal
cos normal cosine goes from negative 1
all the way up to 1 so if we sort of
stretch it out vertically this is not
going to go from
negative one to one anymore it's going
to go from negative from negative three
up to three right so that's what
happened if this is what I were graphing
okay so I'm just going to quickly think
about what that looks like if I sort of
said okay this is from negative 3 to 3
that's what it would look like if it was
just y equals 3 cos x but of course
there's another change that's been made
this negative 2 what does that do this
is not a this is not a scaling or a
stretching thing it's a it's a shift
right where's it gone down with two
units so instead of going from sir let's
have our negatives in the right spot
instead of going from negative 3 to 3
this negative 3 is now gonna be negative
5 right it's gone down two units excuse
me
and this 3 is also going to get it go
down 2 units to 1 is that okay so that's
actually where my new range is going to
be I don't care about these anymore they
were just to help me get a picture of
what was happening so from negative 1
all the way down to 5 sorry positive 1
down to negative 5 that's gonna be my
graph and I'm going to put in all my
relevant positions like so ok now you're
going to get grass like these and a lot
of students will do that and then we'll
move on okay please make this big enough
firstly 1/3 of a page is the general
rule and I've I've almost never seen a
student draw a graph too big but I've
seen hundreds of students draw graphs
that are too small so please draw a
bigger it'll just help you to draw the
features of the graph more accurately
but how do you confirm for yourself that
this is true right if it's correct you
should be able to sort of look at it
from a different angle and get the same
thing okay well we had a look at this
what we did was we took regular cosine
and we applied this three we stretched
it and then we applied the negative two
we shifted it shifted it down okay now
we did it in that order there's no
reason you have to okay if I do it in a
different order I ought to get the same
thing so for instance thinking back to
regular cos okay if I think vertically
where is the middle of the graph
vertically the middle is zero okay in
simple Harmonia which we call this the
center of motion right so if the
zero what does this negative to do what
effect does it have on the center of
motion just like just like we saw before
it's going to move down by two units so
instead of being up here at zero it's
going to go down one down again negative
two
okay but then you can say now that I've
dealt with this negative two at the fact
that it's sort of my through line right
through the middle now I can think about
the inputs you well this is now three
right so I can go three above this
where's that going to go from negative
two up to
one which is my confirmation of what I
had before and from negative two you can
also go down three units to then you're
fine okay so you've got the same region
you had before that you use your
imagination you have the idea okay now
one last thing just to confer for you
because sometimes you get asked the
range which is what I've been focusing
on here that's the main thing that's
been changed sometimes you just get
asked the range as a separate question
okay before you've actually grafted like
part a work out range Part B graph okay
so how would you do this well you could
just sort of use your logic the way that
we've just done that would be okay you
get the right answer but if you want to
rely on actually doing this on paper
here's what you could do this is what
you start with
right and this 3 and this -2 despite the
fact that they're on the right hand side
we have just illustrated the fact that
what they're really changing is not the
X but the Y right there's no there's no
horizontal squeezing or stretching
there's no horizontal shift these two
numbers are really lucky about with this
ok so I'm going to rearrange the
equation to show that right to have
these two in the correct spot I'm going
to what operation will I do to both
sides I'm going to add to both sides
that gives me this and to pop that 3 in
the right spot where it belongs I'm
going to divide both sides by 3 that
gives me this so now that this looks
like what I normally expect with a
normal tree graph right and I know for
this guy
I'm from negative 1 to 1 I can apply
that same logic over here now that I've
rearranged it appropriately
this object over here the left-hand side
should exist between negative 1 and 1 so
you can do this just purely by algebra
right everything that you just told me I
can reverse to apply it to the range
instead of dividing by 3 I'm going to
multiply by 3 which gives me this and
then instead of adding 2 I'm going to
subtract 2 which should give me this
just like I confirmed with my earlier
graph ok so what's nice about this is
whichever where you go you can see
you've got the right answer and you can
confirm that for yourself feel like if I
got the right graph or not we'll try it
another way even if it's just mentally
or scratched on the side of your page so
you can confirm for yourself yes this is
the right graph ok does anyone have any
questions on that I just thought I would
re-emphasize it because I only did this
once in one of my lessons so it's why
they go and this is going to be very
relevant for this task ok I'll leave on
the board just in case you do want to
drop down or snap a picture but whatever
you do please be careful with your
domain and range for these tree graph
questions it's very commonly what
students sort of get mocked up by you
know what about X's that's a great
question
so if you were asked to graph this you
would have to find what those values are
right how are you going to do that in
this question how do you usually find
x-intercepts you let y equal 0 ok so you
can see over here I've actually done
enough work to make this nice and neat
for myself here if I make y equal 0 it's
nice and easy to just get well I've used
a different color improper yeah I'm
gonna get cos x equals 2 over 3 for my
x-intercepts
that's when y equals 0 now 2 over 3 are
you gonna get nice exact values from
that no they're gonna be gross all right
so at this point you know I've got two
PI over here so I know I'm going to be
supplying my answers in radians now what
would you actually do to get these well
you're going to need to roll your
calculator out and find out what these
are they're not going to have nice at
least for you guys not nice like oh 3 PI
on 2 or something like that you're going
to have to get a decimal value for your
radians okay so you've got your
calculator there probably
mostly on your table get your calculator
out go ahead get it up and making sure
that you're on radians
how would you get the angle that belongs
to this cause x equals two thirds what
are you gonna do one operation can you
play both sides come on we let this top
it
you're gonna go inverse close so EMS
cause of two-thirds should give you a
number what is it zero point sorry 84.2
dot okay now have a look you just on the
graph does that seem like one of the
answers that you're expected 0.84
remember what to pay is by the way to
like pie is just 3.14 etc so this is
about six point two eight the zero point
eight four look like one of my answers
it does right I hope it wasn't a very
carefully drawn graph but it sure looks
all like this right now that's good
that's one of the answers but you've got
to how do I find the other one look at
the symmetry of my graph and see if you
can work it out yeah see how this length
is zero point eight four right you can
see visually even on my pretty awful
graph that this length is also zero
point eight four so to get this value
you've got to start at 2pi and subtract
the value that's now sitting in your
calculator display and you should get
what five point four four point five
point four four thank you yeah I'm gonna
get back to Orange so five point four
four now yeah that's a bit gross it's
one of the side effects of using radians
is that you do get these um these
awkward numbers in here but you can
still do a sense check just like you
normally would by remembering that the
whole thing goes to six point two eight
roughly and so yeah that looks pretty
good to me and they're your intercepts
okay